rough night sir when did you return
would make for more comfortable sleeping
arrangements than a piano grand or
otherwise ordinarily I would beg you to
take a night's rest but well we have a
situation I'll explain downstairs ah you
were looking for this I imagine I'll see
you
welcome zija biometric signature
required that's it version 7 line 13
ready for deployment base engage gone
with amateurs
cowl ready for deployment
please begin how calibration routine
calibrating
calibration complete
grass all gun ready for deployment
newest Ospreys include high tensile wire
paid the navigation oven violence and
retrieval of distant object please fire
grappled an apology calibrating
targeting rebels and farming calibrated
scatter ready for deployment software
update allows for crime scene
visualization and multi-layer analysis
please scan target calibrating
Diagnostics Diagnostics calibrated
vector rings ready for deployment
aerodynamically designed were rabid
light and high-impact calibrating
targeting please use a Batarang to hit
the target batter X be quick to utility
belt get three targets to continue
calibration spider rhyme targeting
calibrating Batsuit calibration complete
you know when I can brief you on the
situation